the president's son-in-law and senior
adviser Jared Kushner finally has
official permission to review top-secret
material the White House says that
Kushner has received a permanent
security clearance his temporary access
to top-secret information as you know
was blocked by chief of staff John Kelly
back in February Paula Reed is here with
more on this story Paula good morning
good morning now former justice
officials tell CBS News it's highly
unlikely someone would receive a
security clearance if he's still the
subject of an ongoing criminal
investigation his lawyer says Kushner
sat with the special counsels
investigators for the second time last
month for a seven-hour interview the
questions covered possible collusion
between the campaign and Russia his
contacts with foreign officials during
the transition and issues related to the
obstruction of justice in the firing of
then FBI director James Comey but the
fact that investigators are still asking
key witnesses about collusion and
obstruction undermines the White House's
assertion that this investigation is
wrapping up Nora okay Paula thank you so
much